welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and she-hulk is the marvel disney
plus series coming soon hopefully very
soon starring orphan black actress
tatiana maslany as jennifer walters
attorney and cousin to bruce banner in
new trailer footage released during
disney plus day i gotta react to this
footage give me my first thoughts and
then in a separate video coming tomorrow
i'm gonna break it down frame by frame
for all the details you missed there's a
lot to talk about from today so let's
react to the she-hulk footage here we
go
i'm jennifer walters
yeah you are i'm a normal lawyer
well not that normal these trends what
are triggered by anger and fear don't
make me angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry
what oh
new title very niptucky i like the old
one a bit better i think i am so pumped
for this show she hulk is one of my
favorite characters from marvel comics
from what we can see so far the vfx
looks surprisingly good for a disney
plush show i can't wait to see her face
and just see how that all mixes together
and i love that they're leaning into it
giving her that athletic gear this is
going to do things to people so tatiana
maslany's playing jennifer walters aka
she-hulk she's an attorney cousin to
bruce banner actually in the comics she
gets shot by an organized crime group
that she is prosecuting and bruce ends
up giving her a transfusion which gives
her hulk-like powers but she retains her
consciousness in hulk form and she ends
up kind of staying in that hulk form
permanently she's got swagger she's got
a very satiric sense of humor that
breaks the fourth wall and makes fun of
sexism in the earlier marvel comics she
just really owns it super empowered
super funny super badass she ends up
becoming a member of the avengers and
replaces the thing on a fantastic four
she has some interesting encounters with
some things we're now seeing in the mcu
like the tva as well as a spoiler
warning if you haven't seen eternals yet
and uh have been able to avoid new
rockstar's thumbnails this week she
actually ends up representing arrows aka
star fox in um a sexual assault case
that i doubt we will ever see in the mcu
because yikes this video is sponsored by
expressvpn imagine going to the library
and only being allowed to read from the
periodical section plain but that's kind
of what's happening with your streaming
services right like did you know that
there are netflix libraries in other
countries that have twice as many
oscar-winning movies as the us netflix
well expressvpn is here to help
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen or tracked and can grant
you access to blocked content in your
country you can open yourself up to a
whole new library of content without
having to pay for a whole new streaming
service expressvpn allows you to reroute
your connection to a server in a country
of your choice making geo restrictions a
thing of the past reroute your connect
to the uk and watch rick and morty for
free or european friends can do the
reverse and enjoy all of our us-only
content expressvpn is helpful for
preventing your online data from being
stolen or monitored without your
knowledge and i just like how easy
xpress vpn is to use no confusion no
wasted time and the whole thing runs
fast just fire up the app and connect
with just one click it's the top-rated
vpn provider rated number one by
techradar find out how you can get three
months of expressvpn for free by
visiting expressvpn.com
new rockstars or clicking the link in
the description below now it looks like
they're doing some things differently on
this show we're gonna have like 10
episodes of this each around a half hour
in this case it looks like he brought
her into that gamma lab that he
referenced in avengers end game where he
said i spent 18 months in the gamma lab
trying to mix the brain with the brawn
and here despite seeing mark ruffalo
back in his bruce banner form in the
shang chi post credit scene he's back in
his smart hulk form that is going to be
something we see on this series and he
tells his cousin these transformations
are triggered by anger and fear now we
don't know why he's trying to transform
her what he's trying to trigger it
doesn't look like she's injured here it
just looks like they're testing
something out this could be
post-transfusion and she accidentally
became she-hulk was a bit out of control
before and now he's trying to tell her
how you can get that balance the balance
that he now has as smart hole but in
order to do that he has to trigger her
he has to make her angry fearful and if
she can master that anger that fear she
can just kind of have this permanent
harmony with her she-hulk identity but
in addition this we're also going to see
mark ruffalo and his normal bruce banner
body however this shot looks like it
could be a reflection off a different
surface so maybe we're seeing she-hulk
and smart hulk looking at themselves in
a mirror reflection or maybe having
their astral projected souls out of
their body commune with each other but
hopefully we will get some answers of
why exactly bruce banner appeared in his
human body in that shangshipo's credit
scene is he capable of transforming back
into a human form does he have some kind
of technology or magic that can detach
his human soul from his body and the way
he communicates with other people and
that's just what we were seeing in that
conference call in the shanghai
post-credits scene so in addition to
these two on the show it's also
confirmed that tim robb is returning as
abomination in the mcu in this series we
saw him interestingly in chiang chi
sparring with wong in the macau fighting
club we also know that jamila jamil is
playing mary mcferrin aka titania a
major she-hulk villain who really
matches her strength so a lot of
characters in the show are going to be
boosted via vfx a lot of money is gonna
be poured into this to make this work
because traditionally in marvel the
character of hulk they tend to avoid
showing too much because it costs a lot
of money to animate that but now they
got this disney money that's what your
eight dollars a month is going to i'm
just really excited for the tone of this
it's gonna be a kind of a legal
procedural but also one with a lot of
action and a great sense of humor and
one that's not afraid to show off
she-hulk's feminine side it looks like
there's a shot of her getting out of a
car wearing a nice looking dress showing
off some lag what's so great about the
she-hulk comics is a way that she can
strike that balance own all of the
goofiness of her character like she hulk
to people who don't know the character
think oh you just have to put something
woman or she something in front of it
but no they're totally self-aware of
that they embrace it and that's what
makes it so much fun also tatiana
maslany from orphan black such a
talented performer someone who like
oscar isaac can play infinite versions
of a character all of them charming and
likable characters you root for i'm
ready to see this character step up as a
new leader of the avengers a super sharp
smart legal mind someone who can go
toe-to-toe with the rest of the avengers
but also characters like ren slayer and
mobius in the tva loki sylvie and star
fox she is just kind of like a walking
what the hell and it's gonna be so
representative of what we love about the
mcu going forward be sure to follow new
rockstars for all the big news that's
coming out of disney plus follow me at
eavos follow new rockstars support new
rockstars merch newrockstarsmerch.com
lots of great options there thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you